the jurogan experience now i know that
jimmy is
quick yeah yeah and
uh
i don't know jimmy personally i i like
the guy without knowing him
you interviewed him right very nice guy
yeah that's what i thought yeah
i'd like to get him out in the field
with me and show him some stuff
firsthand i think i bet he would love
that i think he's a giant fan of your
work
i like to hear that well i'm a fan of
his work but i don't happen to agree on
this one well i mean i don't even know
if he agrees i think he's just
speculating yeah he's not dogmatic like
he doesn't have like a rigid perspective
on this yeah here you can see there's
the recap stroke what is interesting
though is look at this
you've got that uh
this structure up here that
terminator
tendon
i knew how to pronounce it but anyways
that's it that's an impact crater there
there's one here we can actually if we
go back
the the
tenure crater and mauritania that's
impact and the
tem mimic chat i
that's exactly so what's interesting
though check this out
there's one there's two and here's the
recap structure
they fall in a perfect alignment
now what's the explanation there i don't
know
it could just be coincidence right it
could be coincidence yeah
one of the things that he said about the
re-cut structure was that around it the
white appears to be salt
which could be and i mean see
the rim rock of this is late cretaceous
about 90 million years old so at that
point it was below the ocean right so
it's been uplifted i think this thing is
about 14 or 1500 feet above sea level
if memory serves me correct so it's been
eroded you see this whole thing here is
like an erosion you had a massive amount
of
water that came down over this and most
likely is what exposed this thing to the
surface it was probably buried
um
let's see here
oh
so
right there is you know from plato
that's the ring to city of atlantis the
scale
the concentric rings the concentric ring
so that this is the actual scale
superimposed onto the recap store so
it's much smaller much smaller scale but
plato's scale was based on what the
stade
it was based on the stade which is
roughly 607 feet
it's where we get the word stadium from
oh wow yeah because that's that was the
length of a stadium in ancient greece so
when you look at plato's version of the
sorry to take you on this detour but i
was just curious when you look at
plato's version of um atlantis
is there an area of the world that seems
likely yeah yeah
yeah
you better watch my six hour
presentation okay i will
yeah no but
i i look
it's detailed that's why even in six
hours
you know i can't really spell it i in my
podcast i did the first nine episodes
two hours each
were devoted to i thought well let's
kick it off with atlantis 18 hours of
atlantis 18 hours of it the last episode
9 was
devoted to the recap structure wow so i
had eight eight hours so 16 hours but we
had some chatter and things like that in
there so maybe more like 12 or 14 hours
so um you know who johanna james is no
she is a
uh british actress who started doing
this pot she's really cool lady um
she's very interested in all this kind
of stuff
very smart
extraordinarily beautiful
and um she
went on and and did a uh
she does these like 20-minute 30-minute
little
vignettes of things that she's really
interested in having to do a lot with
you know ancient cultures all the kind
of things that you know graham hancock
is you know she reads graham hancock she
became a fan of mine and she devoted one
of her little 20 or 30 minute segments
to she said i watched all 10 hours or 12
hours of randall carlson's
programs on atlantis and so she did this
like 30 minute little synopsis of it
really did a great job so
we reached out to her i invited her on
she came on we did a live stream a
couple of weeks ago with her as a guest
and um just really fun lady she's uh
also does comedy right yeah and she's
very intelligent very gorgeous um what
can i say you know and smart and
interested in all this kind of stuff so
you know there we go
anyways um
so she was very interested in the whole
atlantis thing and
so
because of that there was a lot of
feedback and people
wanting to know more and so i thought
okay now the
the 10 or 12 hours i did what i'm going
to do is i'm going to try to condense
that down
so a couple of weeks ago we did the
first three hour live stream where i
basically started breaking down plato's
account line by line what did he
actually say
let's look at the geology let's look at
the geography the oceanography the
astronomy and see if it lines up if it
matches up
and so i think there's one place that
pretty much is not all the details but
when you look at all of the areas around
the planet that have been proposed for
atlantis i think there's one place that
fits the majority of his details and
that's the sunken azores plateau and i
say sunken because we know it's sunken
and it's right along the mid-atlantic
ridge
in fact
since we're on this subject and i wasn't
even thinking would get on this subject
there's the azores plateau right there
it it straddles a triple plate junction
which you have the european plate the
african plate and the north american
plate here it's up near nova nova scotia
yeah it's far north it is but notice
over here it's really almost at the same
latitude as spain
see
and
i would say that if there's any place on
the planet that is most consistent with
plato's account that's it right there
why is that
without doing an 18-hour presentation
oh come on joe can't we have pizza
brought in we can
nah that's why
in a nutshell god where do i even begin
so
uh i was afraid you were going to ask
that but
we could look very quickly i guess like
give you the the five-minute version
um
which is that uh
there is evidence that there was a
massive subsidence along the
mid-atlantic ridge we actually talked
about this a little bit and i think in
our very first
uh discussion we had
which was what
seven eight years ago at least yeah yeah
yeah because and we so we talked about
this a little bit
geophysics shows that there's
horizontal movement lateral movement of
the earth's crust
because of continental drift but there's
also vertical movement
and that is the result of
isostatic compensation
that's called isostasy is the vertical
movement of the earth's crust i can show
you like i should have a slide right
here that will help to really illustrate
what it is uh
let me back up to
uh
let's see
should be right in here
ah here we go
okay so now this is the shore of hudson
bay now this is where the ice sheet was
the thickest right now what are you
seeing there
hudson bay
is up here
these are shorelines
because when the ice was removed the
land started rising back
so here's sea level right land is rising
back and the land is rising because of a
lack of weight of the ice yes
right so you're sitting on a soft
cushiony chair right now right
are you yep okay so your ass is causing
isostatic depression of that cushion on
your chair right right and if you sit up
you'll have isostatic compensation
right so that's what that is along many
many many lines yes those are all
shorelines
here's another view of it
here's another view
wow
that's the land rebounding couple of
thousand feet after the ice was removed
now the ice was removed and all of those
trillions of tons of weight where did it
go
in the atlantic ocean
now you look the thinnest crust on the
earth is the mid-atlantic ridge and if
you look at it you'll see that there are
transform faults
which should show up
right here the transform faults
are these vertical fault lines
that are when you would say orthogonal
or right angles to the ridge itself here
you can see very clearly the the the
triple plate junction
and how the azores plateau okay well
since the 1940s the first exhibition
expedition in 1948
there was a uh when they started doing
uh dredge samples from the uh from the
floor of the atlantic ocean which
coincidentally the name of the ship was
the atlantis
they dredge clore samples they pull up
the core samples from two miles down a
mile to two miles down and they look at
those core samples and what you had was
for example shallow water creatures
living they weren't living they were now
you know they had been drowned you had
creatures like uh that had that
typically lived under a hundred feet of
sea water and now they're a mile mile
and a half below and they're on the
flanks of this of this place right here
so these are fossils that they're
finding yes so and they're finding
fossils that ordinarily you would find
in some place that was very shallow very
shallow very shallow yes or relatively
shallow 100 feet 100 feet yes um so this
is this is the basic idea here this goes
back to the 60s as it says right here
the possible tectonic implications of
glacious static now eustatic is the rise
and fall of sea level
correlated with the increase and
decrease of of glacial ice
so if the ice is increasing sea level is
falling and we call that eustatic sea
level fall if the ice is shrinking
melting sea levels rising so that's a
eustatic rise so that's the the main the
meaning of that when you see
glaciostatic that means the rise and
fall of the sea level as a result of
glacier growth or melting okay
and it says here sea level fluctuations
have received only minor attention in
connection with such problems as ocean
floor spreading the purpose of this
report is to point out that late
pleistocene sea level data suggests that
the ocean basins have responded
isostatically
and by a significant amount
particularly concentrated along the
mid-atlantic ridge
i mean this i i've got so much here i'm
just gonna grab a couple of these things
here yeah so they they dug up these
cobbles which are uh the cobbles are um
so a cobble is basically a stone or
anything that's lithified that's roughly
between
um a pebble
a pebble and a boulder a boulder when
you get i think to 11 inches about about
the size of a volleyball now you're in
the realm of boulders
kabul is in between pebbles and boulders
you know like you've heard of
cobblestone streets you know the other
fist-sized rocks basically so
so
they say here the atlantis crews are in
great meteor sea mounts rise from a
broad ridge or plateau which extends
from the mid-atlantic ridge blah blah
blah let's see um
so about a ton of flat pteropod
limestone cobbles was dredged from the
summit area of one of these
sunken
what they're calling the sea mounts and
the sea mount is like a flat top
mountain right like the top of the
mountain has been sheared off
okay
so they pulled up these limestones right
these limestone cobbles they dated them
one of the cobbles gave an apparent
radiocarbon age of 12 000 years plus or
minus 900 years
the state of lithification how how much
it is turned into rock
of the limestone suggests that it may
have been lithified under sub-aerial
conditions in other words in the
atmosphere that's what that means
it may have been lithified under
sub-aerial conditions and the sea mount
may have been an island within the past
12 000 years wow so i mean we could go
through again
hours of this kind of research and why
it's been pushed off to the side is
anybody's guess
but it just doesn't fit the paradigm
but yeah basically now this doesn't
prove that there was any civilization
there but we can make a very strong case
that a large section of the azores
plateau
was above sea level during the late
glacial maximum does it coincide with
plato's account of trade and of travel
and of the way well we have no way of
knowing see now there we have to make a
leap of faith which is this
if and if we look right here you'll see
uh
you can see it very clearly and you can
see the straits of gibraltar here which
was anciently known as the pillars of
heracles
and
you come here to a group of islands
and then you get to the azores plateau
and here these down here are those
seamounts those truncated seamounts
so
really all you have to do here's the
leap of faith you have to make you have
to go now we don't
i don't get into anything like you know
whatever flying spaceships or crystal
ray guns or anything like that no i just
go by what plato says what he's
describing is a maritime culture that
had navigational abilities something
along the lines of the minoan or the
phoenician culture maybe
by an order of magnitude right so now
all we have to do really is assume this
which to me is not so
pseudo-scientific that we couldn't even
consider which is that somebody some
group in the ice age had
enough navigational skills to sail from
europe to
islands right here